chilan washington surrounded by the
gorgeous cascade mountains situated on
lake chilan this small town is home to
the lake view hotel and bc mcdonald's
restaurant
owners brent and anthony macdonald have
been in business here for over 15 years
we bought the hotel in 2000. we came
into town and
and a lot of the locals they really
didn't want to see us make it they
figured they won't be here long
well i let them know that we are going
nowhere
you're stuck with us
the lakeview hotel is adults only we
think that it's the nicest hotel
probably in the state of washington we
have a great place here busy mcdonald
lakeview hotel but business is really
slow we're losing probably 30 000 a
month
easy
the financial situation here at the
hotel in the restaurant it is tough and
this year it's extremely tough because
we had wildfires in the area and quite
honestly that's what kind of has broke
the bank
the majority of the reason why there's
no consistent business here is brent and
afnie's reputation hon i'm talking i am
talking customers come in and she said
you hurry up you go sit down i'm
training you sit down we'll be with you
a minute
i'm the best employer in town i think
i'm easy to work with just be quiet will
you please you know i don't know why
people don't like to be here if you want
to keep money flowing through the locals
need to like you and you know if you
have a bad attitude towards the locals
or other customers they're not going to
come back
[Music]
get out there and do a little dance come
on
i know you used to pull dance get your
ass out there i definitely get very
embarrassed by some of the things he
says i hope you got a lot of energy
tonight cause baby this is this is
friday night
friday night people are coming to a nice
restaurant they don't want to hear dirty
jokes and cussing and everything like
that brent does not like to be told
anything you can tell him the sky is
blue and he's it's going to upset him
i think that people are lucky to work
for us i think i got a great management
style
chelan is a beautiful town the
opportunity is there
we just get overlooked because of brent
and affinity's reputation
all of our money that we have made in
the last 30 years has been sunk into
this business
and we have so much invested
we cannot stop because otherwise we're
we're done
[Music]
go
[Music]
falcon right
yeah it's not my eyesight
maybe he thinks he has the wrong place
[Music]
valet pumpkin is not
wow
baby
it's the best breakfast lunch and dinner
in town
come on in come on in
good afternoon chef ramsay what a
gorgeous drive that was oh thank you how
are you all with ladies first
i totally understand that
um are we uh the valley parking on
strike
it is this time of year so it's
temporary ballet parking i want to do my
car because you kept the sign there i
i'll park it for you how about that wow
this last time we dusted in here it's a
bit dusty
what's that there
something is growing up there yeah can
you see that or is it me
i can see it wow yeah just right there i
know you're both wearing glasses i just
want to make sure you can see it
it's now it's not real easy to see for
me how did you get that down well you're
going to use that
duster and where is the pole
it's right in the back here i'll be
right back
wow now you've made everything dusty
down here i've made it dusty no you
haven't cleaned it yeah
supposing that
falls on a customer's head what would
you do
i don't think that it will actually oh
you don't think it will no oh it's been
up there for about six months it seems
to
be growing actually that is disgusting
yeah brett shame on you i know it wow
and what's in here
more dust over here brett look there's
there more
you must have missed that spot too
there's a big long green crawling
hanging down yes i see that wow we've
been closed for the last three weeks
when it's so slow this time of the year
we go on a holiday and when you close do
you normally clean before you close or
would you come back dirt uh
come back uh the way it is and wow look
at that up there we're living in a very
uh dusty environment here that's
[ __ ] yeah okay uh come on seriously
this is the mountain clean air well then
i'm honest that's that's all true yeah
oh there you go yeah there we go thank
you for that no problem i i didn't
expect to clean as i check in oh my god
there you go they are gross right don't
mess it up too much it's all gonna come
down well how long are you thinking of
keeping up that
oh [ __ ]
we might as well do them all while we're
at it we might as well do them all yeah
it's not funny i've got to get this
thing out here
holy [ __ ] look at that
[ __ ] damn it daphne why didn't you get
to that
[Music]
and how long have you earned this place
15 15 years 15 years
last time it was cleaned it was clean
you're just good i was you've got it
you've got a great eye i can tell you
dismissed i've done lots of things on
arrival but i've never quite cleaned
[ __ ] like that from a ceiling can i give
that back to you i'll do that okay right
yeah thank you and what's going on here
on the front door you've got 40 flavors
yes sorry no samples yes when we're
really really busy we have a line that
goes out the door
one person ask for uh a sample they will
all ask for a sample and how do you
think all those yogurt franchises entice
business
they offer samples
so they speculate to accumulate
sorry no samples sorry no samples who
comes up with all these stupid rules
probably myself man you like kicking the
crap out the locals don't you yes
so i take it we're not gonna get oh
there's another one yes there's me
thinking that's a flavor
so how long ago did this close oh my god
look how dusty that is it's not closed
this is not closed no it's not stop it
is not it looks like it's oh no
bloody how
where's the stick on please
oh my god this is monstrous
this is like a cobweb on steroids
where's the stick gone she's getting it
so why did you close for three weeks
i went on a holiday wow and where did
you go mexico wow did you enjoy mexico
yeah
really and we enjoyed being here she
only came for a week she gives me
a week by myself
say that again you go on holiday on your
own i do rest for a week and my wife
comes from the second uh my wife and
daughter meet me for the second week
she's not like to go for two weeks
holiday well i would love that if i have
a chance
i see
right
um i just want to get this thing down
here you see the size of this one holy
crap is that a keeper
that
look at that
this is above i'm taking a nice cream
parlor if we turn that on it's going to
spin dust hopefully it won't we'll weak
for that yeah awesome okay now
what
i i think you're doing awesome actually
i i think that we should yeah possibly
hire him really you know i'm glad that
i'm hired to clean
yeah
wow do i have to take this to my room it
might be a good idea are you serious no
let's go no dust right
oh [ __ ] whilst i'm up here look oh come
on look at these ones here on the top of
that we'll get it oh now you'll get it
well it's obvious that you haven't done
it before let's go you know
how many rooms you have here 12 12. wow
this room probably isn't for you but
we're going to give it to you anyway
what do you mean by that it's for people
that haven't been laid for a while quite
honestly say that again sorry
people that haven't been laid laid
laid as in as in
what's that got to do with me checking
into this room
wow
and this is the room
for those who haven't been laid recently
you don't talk like that to guests
well this is an awesome room it offers
the best view that we have right of the
river part of lake chelan wow has a
stacked stone fireplace awesome ceiling
i think they're 15 feet and uh awesome
dusty ceiling see those beams i can see
yeah i see that a little bit man what is
it with dust around here well as i said
we're in a dusty area
apart from the dust the rooms are
gorgeous
yes
these are the air conditioning uh units
where's that so you don't have that
funky thing down here that cries motel i
thought it was a tv no it's uh air
conditioning it's both we program it for
both ac or right so where do i adjust
the temperature uh you don't they're
preset it's set at 68 degrees wow why is
it set like that i keep the remote
controls because i absolutely know that
they will get screwed up if i leave them
up here in the room you don't give
samples you don't let me keep the
remotes and you don't let me bring the
temperature up or down it's not really
the get laid room is it
that's up to you
wow you're setting the bar you're you're
telling me what i can and what i can't
do
weird it's very weird look how dusty
this is as well
how do i open that up
so you've got all these photos would you
like me to open it yes please thank you
wow
when was the last time they were cleaned
that gets cleaned about twice a year
would you mind if i just make it
three times this year yeah i think that
sounds great actually
okay
so the air conditioning unit you control
they have to breathe in this [ __ ] at
night
are you bullshitting me no i'm not
shooting you
right can you uh i will take that your
mind i've got no interest in breathing
your dust
okay i'm gonna unpack and i'll be down
in five minutes okay please
wow
honestly look at that
it's terrible
disgusting
[Music]
hello hi
man um
the dust when i walked in what the hell
was going on
bizarre how long have you been here a
month so you're a new kid on the block i
am yes wow do they go through a lot of
stuff i think so there is some that have
been here for years but actually
the ones that were here the cooks they
have
recently left and
i mean how would you describe them as
bosses um
[Music]
different than any i've ever had yeah
i'll say anyway let's order um obviously
i was gonna have a glass of wine hoping
to get something local having just
driven through those amazing vineyards
but there's nothing local here no
i mean
new zealand sauvignon blanc how weird
what would you recommend for lunch
what's the soup today the soup is a
minestrone oh that's good yeah uh bc's
bacon burger yeah okay
let's do a pizza as well
right sorry actually we don't do the
pizzas any longer
i don't know why the page is not taken
out wow okay uh anything else that's not
on we are out
of the pork stir-fry and we do not have
chili ah no chili
let's do a prime rib as well with that
shall we
um
i believe we're out of primrose
all right we're out i believe so yeah
the um turkey ciabatta dip is
usually a good one let's let's do a
turkey dip okay um
hold on a minute breaking news bc soon
to be famous
steak what the [ __ ] does that mean when
someone says soon to be famous who
writes this [ __ ] on the menu it seemed
to be famous why would that be on the
menu i think we should try it let's go
um i think we're done okay yeah sure
yeah thank you
okay do you need help
the ministry suit right correct
excellent
wow that doesn't even taste homemade
it's frozen
it's frozen
yeah frozen minestrone soup yeah
this is terrible
we've got the bc bacon burger
wow
jeez look how thin that is my onion
ring's thicker than my pate
huh
where are they from
i'll find out that answer
on the hamburgers it says on the menu
certified angus beef where do we get
that are they fresh or frozen no we
always come back it's frozen 12.95
let's have a cooked and the the pate is
bland it actually tastes frozen but
please tell us
it does come frozen
so
it says fresh and it's not anywhere near
13 for that
oh that's the food coming out it's very
good this is the um turkey milk thank
you and what's this here
that is the broth for the turkey
if you want to get beer sandwiches
just have a little sip
wow it's so salty yes it's so bad
it's salty and bitter jesus you want to
taste this actually
he had me tasted oh yeah it's really
salty really salty yeah
holy [ __ ]
this here is the teriyaki chicken
[Music]
the nearly famous burger what the [ __ ]
what is that
what's he doused it in
terricky over cheese
oh
nearly famous because it's about to be
famous to send me
to the bathroom
yeah i mean i'm gonna go there
nope
i'll just have a coffee okay
right
let's get reviewing
wow headline do not go here if you want
mediocre overpriced food this is the
place for you unfortunately not my dig
bloody hell well this is terrible
this is terrible oh it's awful i mean
look at the headlines what are not place
the owner batman another local place at
our table do not go here run run run far
away horrible service terrible food and
stupid expensive the owners are jerks
who are rude and don't support their
staff they don't welcome kids no wonder
this place is empty
they're that bad
it is it's very awkward you know anthony
says they don't listen to this these are
customers they're all negative and fyi
no samples allowed
that's right it's a tight bastard yeah
is he really stingy absolutely yeah and
the lack of your children
and they do have a teenage daughter so
they have a teenage daughter but they
don't welcome kids yes
he goes on holiday for a week on his own
sons himself gets nice and bronzed then
she joins him for the second week but he
wants the week on his own
ah it's just like a full wow
i have not heard that
yeah what a creep yeah
if i did that to my wife it should keep
me in the nuts yes
i'm at a loss this place is depressing
i'd like to um get the owners down here
let's just have a little debrief shall
we okay thank you
wow jesus christ do you want us he does
yeah let's go it's okay to give you some
funding don't say anything do not make
like fun
you think that it's not start
[Music]
i'm at a loss the biggest
kick in the balls for me is that on the
menu it states
homemade
fresh daily changing soup of the day
your soup of the day
brent is frozen
can you make minister only soon yes how
much it cost to make a liter a couple
bucks tell the owner
and you have the nearly famous burger
i'd like to congratulate you
because it's now famous
as the most disgusting bit of [ __ ]
between a bun i've ever seen
you have a slice of red onion that's
thicker than your pate it was frozen and
you're charging 13.95 for it
i don't know how low we can go
the list everything's from new zealand
there's not even a local wine on here
well
give it to me then i'll give it to you
most of these wineries all opened up
restaurants
they're they're our competitors so you
can't support a local vineyard
well i came in here to help
i'm laughter lied to
and fed frozen food
as an owner you too can't be that god
otherwise i'm gonna go
[Music]
right before dinner i had a chance to
catch up with teddy the manager
so could understand his perspective of
what anthony and brent are like as
owners inappropriate things are commonly
said his personality has a lot to do
with it it's you know really common that
he'll make you feel that this is the
best place and you're lucky to be here
their behavior as bosses is unacceptable
wow
wow
clearly in denial i appreciate the
insight yeah yeah
thank you thank you i'll see you in
there yes definitely and i want to
observe what they're like during an
evening at the lakeview
so you have a key to the room
but let's hope that it's ready a couple
things that we're not offering um no
chilean sea bass no pizza so no pizza no
pizza no sea bass
very
[ __ ]
disappointing
know
frozen frozen frozen
wow i'm not even wrapped
where are the burgers
i mean it just doesn't look anything
like a burger and when it's processed
like that and stamped and pressed you
can just tell right frozen food wow
brett come with me yeah how's the
fettuccine
it's okay
not the best damn i'm sorry
um burgers
a burger cooked here locally would you
expect that to be frozen or fresh
fresh
the burger's not frozen it's the patties
and everything come in frozen when
they're thought out is that like most
people just pulled it out so it's not
freezing
it comes in
frozen yeah you thought out and that to
your customers is not a frozen burger
well
[Music]
stay there let me just show you
something
[Music]
i'm waiting for him to come back he's
going to dream me on something
oh boy here we go
so there's your burgers it's a frozen
thank you
now your husband said it wasn't no what
do you mean no it's it's it's frozen of
course i never said that it wasn't it we
thought out here it comes in frozen yeah
it's still a frozen burger there's no
such thing as a fresh burger at least at
least here in eastern washington
we cannot get fresh there's no fruit you
find me the burger come with me yeah
good evening welcome please come in at
the cold dinner yes quick question do
you love a burger yeah
would you expect them to be made fresh
here or frozen fresh fresh
are you going to tell them what should i
tell them
fresh all the way no should we tell them
the truth i mean that's what we wanted
well we we sell uh our burgers come in
frozen and we thaw them out
but thawing them out doesn't make them
french
thank you appreciate it thank you thank
you thanks for coming you guys
welcome ladies hey folks how are you
quick question
coming out for dinner would you expect a
frozen burger to be served here tonight
or a fresh one fresh fresh you gonna
tell him what should i tell him
i'll let you tell him oh come on you own
the place well we all of our
beef that we get in burgers it comes in
frozen
our burgers and we and we thaw him out
which in his mind convinces him it's
fresh
does that make it sound any better no
thank you
we're still glad to have you thank you
you bet
oh my god
after brent tried to convince me that
there were no fresh burgers in town
i almost cried it's okay you did good
i'm proud of you i walked directly
across the street and ordered one so
that's the lamb burger
[Music]
nice to see you coming to a restaurant
like this would you expect your burgers
to be fresh or frozen fresh
burgers come in frozen
and we thaw them out
that's the story
thank you
so
that is a lamb burger
fresh
and getting sick to death of this denial
denial denial you've been making that
[ __ ] all [ __ ] day yes
yes you have all your staff are the same
thing to say
passive aggressive condescending
inappropriate and stubborn
no absolutely not the staff the way you
treat them what there you go again
no no no you're just scared about
employing a team that's gonna tell you
the truth that is [ __ ] that is nice
because you don't like them confronting
you with the truth yes you'll fire them
no i haven't found anybody i heard that
you fired your son
oh [ __ ]
you don't even know the [ __ ] story
he was having some issues gordon and i
told him the alcohol problem i was aware
of that right i was trying to save his
life yeah my brother's a drug addict we
put him in rehab seven times
unsuccessfully i don't give up on him
but what i'm more concerned about is
that
nothing's affecting you it's like we're
doing great
in general the place runs quite well
oh my god
come with me just you and i
is this a joke for you you know his two
minutes please no is this are you
[ __ ] around no i'm not [ __ ] wrong
are you trying to
pull the ball out of my eyes oh hell no
you know the business is dwindling so
you've got all these rules
no [ __ ] samples
no [ __ ] kids
this place is thriving with families we
really don't want to have crying kids
here i just i just would like to have a
quiet getaway for for our honeymooners
and
birthdays and anniversaries a honeymoon
venture they come down to romantic
dinner and eating a frozen burger
come on
this place is hemorrhaging money
because you're caught in a web
delusional stubborn
old-fashioned
and [ __ ] pompous
anything else
it's just a check for you isn't it no
i'm just next time i'm gonna know
to do a little dusting
wow a little dusting [ __ ] me other
looted
[Music]
during dinner service i decided to do
some investigating in the rooms
and after what i found i gathered the
hotel guests along with acne and brent
hey guys come through please um just
very quickly
glasses on
there we are come through if you just
stand over here pillow left hand side
pillow number one hmm
can you see that i can't see it you
can't see maybe aphny yeah explain to
brent what this is uh spot who knows
spot you don't know yes but maybe this
one will be a little bit clearer
blood
there we go
well that's disgusting right aphny yes
brent can't see anything i i i uh go
ahead where i see that of course okay
let's see
this is the worrying bit
these are the
duvets that have been on these beds that
was just washed one week ago every
single one of them absolute rubbish and
look at this
i mean these customers are they're the
ones you're taking the money from don't
you dare tell me that was washed a week
ago one week ago i have the dolls
cannot be serious we are serious it was
done and that's that's it we're not
going to say that
right
that is not clean oh that's [ __ ] it
was yeah [ __ ] and this
go on oh
i see that but one week ago that was
cleaned i'm done with this [ __ ] this
is how it is
we did 13 of them one week ago and
they're not cleaning them properly stop
just for once today [ __ ] lying
[Music]
and look at this
i mean that is not clean that was just
washed one week ago stop just for once
today lying let it stay there two
seconds
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
did you have any idea you're sleeping in
that
no not at all
i wish you can't see that i want to
sleep in that
prince
i see that i want an explanation because
all you've done since i've arrived here
is lied to me lie to me lied to your
staff and i am not going to allow you to
lie to the customers
and i totally [ __ ] disagree with that
too i have not said one lie to you i'm
not gonna go for that yes you have no i
think that is blind [ __ ] die it's
not true you convinced that thought food
is fresh food
you're robbing them of their cash you're
telling me this was cleaned a week ago
let me ask you a question in front of
your customers would you sleep on that
no
so why'd you expect them to
would you sleep on that no not an
apology
nothing
i'd like to apologize i'm i'm appalled
i'm disgusted
i've had enough
anything you'd like to say the pillars
like this i apologize
can i have a word with him on my own
would you mind
these guests are hours away from putting
their heads on your pillows
blood stained pillows
semen stained duvet covers
and sweat
accumulated over years i can see that
gordon
i am struggling i'm struggling with your
husband that's in denial i'm struggling
with these arrogance and i'm struggling
with these blatant lies i'm not here to
butt heads with a liar i'm here to help
turn this business around
afne you can talk to me
are you worried about brent
he's my husband yes i am
it's my life
we have a daughter together
does your daughter feel this at home
yeah
and he fell out with his son
he fired his son
yeah does that still bother him
is that what it is
he's still his son
of course he's still his son
i still care about him it doesn't sound
like he's caring about him
the guy was drinking
he needed help
so he got rid of him
is that what's bothering him is that why
he's in denial i need brent to take his
guard down something inside here is
bothering him
i don't know if it's the financial debt
the pressure is it his son i don't know
i can't get in
i want to talk to his son
how could i get hold of him i got his
number thank you
anthony
you're the only hope i've got
can we work together yeah and can we get
him to open up
okay
and tomorrow morning i want the truth
and nothing but the truth
okay
[Music]
i really needed to break through to
brent and to see why he is so stubborn
so my team and i attempted to get hold
of his son to meet me at the hotel
but we were unsuccessful
now it's up to me to try to get through
to brent
[Music]
let's take a seat at the bar
i've got to get through to you why are
you so stubborn you got [ __ ] off last
night i mentioned your son
why did that hit a nerve
you know we just had a breakdown in the
relationship when his when his mom
remarried
uh they she remarried the same day the
divorce was final so party company with
your son
you weren't even present at your
daughter's wedding ah
i was not invited i didn't even know she
got married
i was destroyed
everybody wants to see their daughter
i've i've got three daughters
that's painful
you know when you're
when your uh kids tell you
i don't know tell you what
well oh
i have three grandkids
i haven't even seen two of them
you know what
you know i am stubborn maybe i'm
discovered but
when you get shut off and then their mom
died
i thought wow maybe this is going to be
my chance maybe they're going to come to
me
but moist are you kind of my son just
drinks two goddamn water but how
you're still their father
you're still their dad i annoyed
you can't go round with that
that that
that that anger
i i i've been waiting for them to come
to me instead instead of the others
that's never going to happen yeah well
that's that's my proudness and my
stubbornness you know
you have to change your ways and you
have to start becoming a lot more
generous as a owner as a father
responsible for three kids and i i'm not
here to fix your family
i'd love you too i would so [ __ ] love
you too
and just you calling them making an
effort they need to see the change but
you need to embrace that i agree there's
too much at stake
reach out to those kids you've got to
bring those barriers down and you've got
to open up and somewhere in there
there's the friendly
comforting supportive you know astute
brent we've got to get back there okay
brent and anthony's bad reputation
within the town comes as no surprise
you've got a picture there
great give me two minutes please okay
i've gathered local business owners to
show brent and athlete the issues they
don't realize they have good morning
good morning how are we good
first of all i just want to say a big
thank you for coming you guys are the
pillars of the community you have
businesses and you are very proud of
what you've built here
and i've been struggling trying to get
through
to brent
he's in denial i feel like
brent is an undertaker those people that
are working for him there aren't many
that have very good things to say
i had a friend that used to work here at
bc's and she had a customer that had a
steak dinner and a baked potato it was
all great
and he wanted to take it with him so she
took it in the back and set it on the
counter and went to get it to go
container and afnie
scraped it into the garbage and she said
would uh my customer kind of wanted to
take that and she watched anthony grab
the baked potato wipe it off
and grab the stuff
and she made her give that to the
customer no
no free samples on the ice cream how
hard is it to give somebody a little
plastic spoon
what do they give back to the town they
are absolutely no part of this community
they have built walls around themselves
and you need to take care
of each other in the off season it's
locals taking care of locals you know i
will say with the fires you know this
whole town came together and
i don't think i can remember them
offering help in any way
it was a crisis that everybody found a
need and everybody helped yeah accept
that except them but that's the spirit
of chelan i think is what we're getting
at we share tractors we share you know
from vineyard work to some of us have
restaurants so we share employees he's
oblivious
how come there's no wine
from this amazing region on their list
when we first started our winery his
excuse was that the wineries have
restaurants that compete with his
restaurant
in addition to that it would be a shame
if there was just one good place in town
to go to we want tourists come here and
have a great time everywhere they go so
if if he does well we'll all do well
i really appreciate the feedback but i
want you to help me
get through them on another level now
because i'm gonna go and get them
and we're gonna tackle this head-on
uh give me two minutes thank you so much
it's really really hard to take it let's
go because we try really hard it just
shocked me wow
hi hi folks these are in my minds
even more important than customers
because you guys should be bonded
clearly you're not
why is it taking so long
sometimes you need somebody to slap your
face
we were in a comfort zone somewhat
and uh used to the way we did everything
you know for a lot of years and it needs
to be changed
maybe we banked on the location too much
there's a lot of things we've done wrong
they're desperate to see you do well
anything to say there can never be too
many fun
good places in town we always want
somewhere to go and relax and enjoy
ourselves i think we all want you back
on our radar
all of this has been a wake-up call for
us this is part of the reason why we
asked chef ramsey to come to help us
we're listening we heard everything that
you had to say
and we are going to try to do much much
better
we're hearing you
i don't think that i knew how
the business community was connected
that everybody is feeding off of each
other we have to realize that to be part
of this connection we have to change
with brent and acne committing to change
my team moved forward getting rid of all
the dust and cobwebs
we furnished all the rooms with brand
new bedding but the biggest change was
overhauling the ice cream parlor
off we go ladies welcome
my god
holy moly
wow
unbelievable unbelievable
this is what i call a parlor you had a
dreadful space here yes oh my god now
it's turned into something magical
do you think there's any chance that i
could get a sample
we will be throwing samples out
everywhere
this is way beyond our expectation
[Music]
given the importance of the local
wineries
i brought in similar dave foss
who repaired the bad reputations with
the locals that brent and anthony had
you're going to need to nurture those
relationships
and he created a brand new menu
featuring all washington wine you're no
longer going to have to say
sorry i don't have any local wines
finally to accompany all this i created
a smaller more exciting menu that
features all fresh food
dig in have a little taste oh my god
this is so good it's delicious oh my
gosh
everything fresh better
fantastic
what i have learned from this community
is that local support is everything and
this town is willing to give brent and
athlete a second chance nice everybody
how are you today good to see you guys
would you like to see my new ice cream
parlor here with all the new
improvements i'm hoping brent and
anthony make a good impression for the
people of chelan i actually brought you
a list of a lot of the purveyors that we
work with cool oh you want a chicken
how are you guys
the hotel is booked up this is just
gorgeous and the guests will sleep well
tonight in the brand new bedding we've
added to all the rooms
all right
i'm gonna try the barrel salad there's a
real buzz about the new menu
and the kitchen is easily executing the
dishes a quiche
a chicken sandwich and i got the salmon
okay
what we're trying to do is just focus on
the local wineries
with the help of similar dave foss
the customers are pleased with the local
selection of wines they're offering at
bc mcdonald's you like that it's really
good
yeah
i'm always making a mess that's the idea
i'm the official scooper the ice cream
shop is a hit
and brent is even happy giving away
samples if you drop it on the floor you
own it
right
with everything a success i'm hoping
brent makes one important rule change
with this hotel have you thought about
what i mentioned about the children
regarding
children in the hotel are you still
sticking with no children you know what
i'm going to stick to the adults only i
don't certainly
why
well look at when you take two or three
or four children up there and i'm going
to tell you they wipe out the whole damn
place what the noise noise crying
whatever uh
gum
uh pop and god forbid samples of ice
cream they won't have a young daughter i
know i'm talking three four eight year
old have you asked yourself the concept
you know what i'm missing on turnover
revenue we may miss a few but i think we
miss a few on the other end if there
were two or three kids running down the
hall
but not every every kid is is that noisy
i mean just trying to be open with maybe
a couple rooms i will give it thought
that's a tough one
[Music]
i'm disappointed brent won't alter his
rules about allowing kids at the hotel
but hopefully after seeing the success
of the relaunch he'll change his mind
keep up the good work yes ryan
do not let him go back absolutely not
okay well done thank you
are you living yes i am
everybody now in this town is rallying
around for your success yes so embrace
it watching you stand behind that
counter just giving samples out and
seeing the light on the kid's face is
extraordinary it's awesome please don't
go back
stay strong
there's an amazing guy underneath all
those layers
there is yes there is i'm just there is
thank you there is you can do this okay
i can do it yeah take care thank you so
much
okay
and he's gonna think about getting some
kids in here okay okay yeah we're
working on it i'm serious this is
stubborn okay
a couple of scoops of ice cream goes a
long way oh boy it's really gone down
hasn't it
okay thank you take care good night okay
bye
despite my help with the outreach of the
community
brent quickly reverted back to his old
ways
distancing himself from the locals
much of the staff have left or been
fired
and the hotel's reputation within the
town has only gotten worse
[ __ ]
i don't know i don't know where in the
hell everybody's at
[Music]